do you remember your first ever
performance
yeah my mom used to put me in I don't
remember which one was first I just have
memories of doing these things my mom
would enter me into pageants like
literally pageants because so I could
sing in the talent portion yeah but then
you would have to also do the evening
wear and you know I gotta be honest with
you I knew you were going to answer with
this and I just wanted to hear you talk
about that yes
yes yes yes I did those things I don't
remember but I do remember my two
Specialties were I did uh Old Time Rock
and Roll by Bob Seger and I will do Cat
Scratch Fever by Ted Nugent which didn't
go over very well with the soccer moms
in the audience because I don't know if
you ever heard that song or what it's
about but you can imagine I think did
your evening wear end up helping you win
though you just went you just want to
see the pictures you want you want some
pictures to have in your house what's
the meaning behind the name of the album
though queen of me okay so queen of meme
really does uh summarize all of that
sense of
uh personal identity owning ownership of
your identity
um
stainless and I drive my own bus I'm the
boss of me I am the queen of me I'm not
the boss of anyone else I'm the boss of
myself and that means that I take
responsibility for my decision making
for if I you know if I'm in a down
spirit it's up to me to pick myself up
yeah so I start getting into my
songwriting because that's that's what I
do when I get bored or when I'm too
isolated me too and I right yeah and I
personally where I work it out that's
where you work it out it's therapy so
I'm thinking okay I'm gonna just write
myself into a better Spirit I'm gonna
write songs that make me want to dance
and make me feel happy yeah you have a
song I want to talk about it's called
inhale exhale yeah what's that about
what a cool title what a Cool vibe yeah
inhale exhale I affectionately call the
song air
um with everyone suffering from you know
the covert is such a respiratory
um
uh you know infection that really
can take your life very very quickly I
had a bad bout with it I won't go into
it but when I was released from the
hospital the first thing I did
was write down a list of things that air
gives us obviously life yeah
but I'm I'm thinking okay cheer yourself
up what does air give us that is very
celebratory so I'm thinking champagne
bubbles balloons you know I love where
your brain went sailing no it's true
it's like you know uh air with that with
the air we can sail we can fly we can we
can fly a kite we have all these lovely
things to celebrate about
um air and of course like I said you
know life itself so I wrote the song uh
um what are you gonna do without that
air you know inhale exhale so that's the
most inspired song on the album yeah I
love that though when it comes from real
life and then you come up with this
completely different concept off of that
one moment well because I didn't want to
look back on it I'm like okay I'm
through it uh write a happy song about
surviving it and celebrate I love that
you do that we are so different so I'm
gonna try what you do I usually write
when I'm sad and I get it out I've never
written to become happy which is Maybe
I'm finding in this interview but that's
a very clever thing to do to use your
gift for like to write to be happy
usually it's I'm writing just to get it
out I guess I become happy after getting
it out but like I've never had the
mentality of that anyway it's a great
fit I mean no songwriting is venting of
course that's a great place to vent
running you know but I mean welcome to
my albums but writing songs
um I do it as an exercise also to
challenge myself so I of course I write
lots of songs that are very melancholy
very dark if I'm really upset and mad I
put it all in the song yeah um but then
I go back to it later and I turn it
around just like a writing exercise I
just turn it around and now I make it
just like you would putting a song into
first person you find the light yeah
that's cool yeah it's nice to meet you
pleasure to meet you yeah meet over here
[Laughter]
who's working though I'm always working
you're always working I've already
talked to the pillow someone was
actually it's okay it's a very cute
outfit thanks yeah given a little bit of
Yeehaw energy love it had to do it it's
like yeehaw and rock and roll a little
hairstyles moment yeah that's always a
good moment I like his style yeah no pun
intended
um people were asking me backstage or
like you you've known her for a while
and I was like yes I've known it for a
while and now we have a song together we
do me you and which are no peers we do
it just I can't actually tell that full
story on TV but it's
quite funny that recording day for me
I asked Kelly to be a part of my song in
the morning and she went to the studio
that night and did vocals
[Applause]
thank you I'm gonna give you a little
I'm gonna give you a little bit of it so
she I it's my last day of work I have
told Trisha my assistant and my group
I'm like I can't do anything the day I
checked you the day you texted me I had
literally been like look this has to be
on this day then I'm off I was like I
promised myself this summer and not only
you text me but Shane mcanally are a
friend who's also a singer-songwriter
and anyway he you both texted me and
they're like oh we got this on I was
like oh I love Kelsey I was like okay
let me just listen to it I was like I
was like oh I have to do this well
I had already been celebrating
I do know this story I had already been
celebrating that it was my last day of
work
okay so I so I get to the studio here at
this studio with Jason and I get in
there and I'm like look
I didn't know I was gonna be singing
today
I don't know so I had to sing a song
called you're drunk go home
inebriated trying to sing for soprano
Parts like I'm fine like I there is an
actual full track we have to send it to
you of me just crying and laughing so
hard I almost peed my pants because I
was like this has never happened to me
in 20 years I've never ever been
inebriated while singing something and I
am while singing you're you're drunk go
home so there there is there is this one
yep it's a great song it's a great song
there's one ad-lib I didn't know I had
already started and then you texted
there's one part
um on the song where it's like
um an ad-lib track and now you're gonna
hear it and now you're gonna know and
you just hear Kelly go bye
and it's in there and it's cranked so
thank you for that air welcome thank you
um so what do you each remember from
like the very first time that you all
played together was it like awkward or
like you knew right away it was gonna
work well Natalie had joined the band uh
a previous lineup and so Marty and I
were very like nervous like well she
rehearsed all the songs and know all the
songs now he was just like oh I got this
y'all I got that because it's confidence
and Marty and I are just like oh my gosh
oh my gosh but Natalie brought this
humongous pad with her lyrics on it I
would just flip it in between the songs
we played these two clubs in outside of
Houston yeah and I would just
bend down Turn the Page oh my god do you
have a problem with lyrics I do no but I
had to learn 22 songs in seven days I
would just listen with headphones and
and yeah I never yodled before
that's a lot I know oh my gosh so the
tour is for your album gaslighter A lot
of people relate to this album and the
message and
um and just I guess from an artist's
point of view like how hard is it asking
for a friend while I'm currently writing
um through a similar situation is how
hard is that to write so openly and so
honest while navigating children while
navigating
people you know you're under a
microscope like there's so much like I
feel like I've written so many songs
myself for my personal like life and I
keep kind of going oh should I do that
or oh God or is that I did you go
through that like while writing this
um I definitely wanted to be very
blatant and like literal with this one
but um yeah I was still I wasn't like
beyond all the emotion like I am now and
then there's a stress of oh my gosh now
my kids are going to hear this and then
yeah now my son is on tour with us he's
in the band and I'm like this is kind of
weird
hahaha
I'm always checking are you okay are you
all right
it'd be awkward yeah but I but I love
the fact that like he's an artist so he
does get the fact that like it's very
therapeutic for us to like that's our
Outlet like that's no way around it when
you write falsely it doesn't work it's
transparently yeah you have to be real
agree sorry I was so boring it's weird
the more specific you are the more it's
Universal to other people which isn't
Dad I know okay so you also just
released a greatest hits collection
called diamonds and redstones I love the
title um is it true that yours on Two
Doors Down was about fried clams it was
but see I need this story I'm like you
no I've always had a problem with my
weight too up and down I love to eat
I've been up and I've been exercising
the world and a long time ago yeah it
was getting me depressed I didn't like
it so I was you know you try everything
to you know to lose weight and I had got
on some kind of crazy old diet like a
liquid protein you just drink ounce of
something that's ground up horse hooves
I don't know her monkey pee or something
I don't know but it was just yeah but
you're supposed to drink it like three
times a day and it was so ungodly you
just have to close the back of your
throat off so you don't smell you know
how it goes but no thanks we we used to
stay at the Howard Johnson's Motor Lodge
the band when we travel back in the
early days and they had a restaurant
there and they had these fried clams
that we couldn't wait to stop to go to
Howard Johnson's even if we weren't
staying over we'd stop to eat the fried
clams yeah but we were staying over and
I was on that stupid liquid protein diet
and the band was down in the kitchen and
I was in the in a hallway in my room and
I could hear them all laughing and
talking that's what I'm saying you could
start saying I was just saying uh like
uh two doors down two doors down there
laughing and drinking and having a party
but two doors down they're not aware
that I'm round but here I am just crying
my heart out feeling sorry
having a party just two doors down I was
just sitting there feeling sorry for
myself because I was eating fried clams
I love that that song is about now and
it was two doors down I was saying two
of those down from the restroom that's
why
seriously well you recently posted a
photo of your pawpaw yeah and I didn't
know this story but I didn't know that
your real last name wasn't all Dean yeah
so my last name is Williams okay um very
different but yes so when I was in high
school and started playing music there
was a couple basketball players named
Jason Williams and so and there was a
piano Guy in Nashville named Jason D
Williams so it's just so common you know
and so I started using my middle name
which was Aldine and my grandfather who
I was named after my grandfather and so
I had a cousin in town the other day and
we started talking about him and and my
uncle years ago had started taking my
grandfather out and he would just record
you know had a little recorder and he
would record conversations and he put
him on a CD so I've been driving around
in my truck listening to those CDs and
and my cousin was in town we were
talking about him and and so that night
I just kind of had the feels as you say
exactly did you cry no judging you I
didn't I didn't but it's just cool I was
named after him and uh it was a name
growing up that I was like man I always
whenever somebody called me Jason Aldean
it was usually because I was in trouble
yes so little did I know that that would
be the name that everybody would know me
as you know from now on and he didn't
live long enough to to kind of see that
you know so I was just kind of thinking
about him a lot that night and and uh
but then I ended up naming uh my only
son after him too Memphis Aldean so yeah
such a cool name thank you such a strong
walking real name
um this is this is awesome and I love
that it's smoke the night yeah so nine
what's the significance so non for me
this was an album I know it's your ninth
album yes ninth album but uh for me this
was an album that years ago I just kind
of it was a pipe dream but I always said
if I ever made nine records I was going
to call it nine or number nine because I
played a lot of baseball growing up I
actually thought that was going to be my
career path for a long time and uh and
nine was my number that I wore playing
baseball all those years and so oh look
at itty BBC
look at you oh there you go there you go
high school and no facial hair right
here if you're busy with like this
amazing record that I'm very excited
about I got to sing on it
I got to sing on it and I'm very excited
about it here because I only got to hear
the songs you let me hear that I was
singing on so I'm then I got the record
and I just literally you never fail to
impress me with like your voice it's
insane like literally like it's insane
how talented you are like your record is
amazing and you know what I love about
it is you stick to country music it
sounds like country music well it's what
it's what I grew up on him it's what I
love it's the music that I was
influenced by I'm a big Linda Ronstadt
fan and you know that stuff has fiddles
and steel guitars all over it she
crossed genres yeah yeah that was really
cool so I'm I'm not a traditional
country singer but I definitely fall in
the country category and I just want to
tell you guys when Kelly came in to sing
on the record I've been asked about this
in every interview I've been doing this
week about the album release I'm like
I'm like what is it about Kelly I'm like
she's not real like she's not normal
like she's just amazing it's crazy and
she comes in and she just you know I
hear this High strong Harmony and I know
I'm not gonna sing it and I'm like Kelly
can you come over and do this for me and
it's just amazing what you bring and I
know you could probably everyone you've
seen with you make them sound better but
I love our voices together oh my God I
love singing with you yeah let's do more
what's funny is actually the first thing
we got to record together was prize
better and I got there and I had no idea
that our husband was gonna be like
producing it and I was like uh and I got
in the studio and I'll tell you I've
never been more nervous about sounding
good because I was like you're there
already that was nerve-wracking enough
and then your husband who's you know
Garth freaking Brooks walks in and he's
like
[Music]
and literally he he was producing me I
was peeing my pants I was like
worth but anyway I was trolling my
session to try to get you to work with
him that's totally what he was saying
I was about to die because I was so
nervous but both of you I mean it's just
admit you're just such this power
and it's like uh please if you go back
and listen to the Enterprise but I don't
know if you remember this at the end we
were there were these licks at the end
and so we were kind of doing these
answers to each other and I remember
that I had done something and you went
in and then you did your lick and I'm
like let me go back in there like give
me another shot at it so I went back in
and did it again let me go back in there
I was very nervous but it was amazing
but he's actually really cool I was
worried does he ever crash your girls
nights to see he doesn't because he
seems funny he's a little afraid of that
many women together so he really doesn't
like he will but if he is if he's around
he'll open the wine but he really wants
to be gone like he'd rather be like I
think it scares him a little bit as it
should you know women a bunch of women
yeah and here's something else about you
men
Designing Women episode you're writing
everything well as promised I found some
old photos of you are you ready to go
through oh boy I'm excited all right all
right let's see what you go first one
[Applause]
oh my gosh how old are you there I think
second grade oh my God you're adorable
look at that you had that big old hair
going even then you were like y'all
ain't ready for my hair okay next
yeah
yeah okay I mean
it looks like you're about to fall with
a horse but you're not okay two things
about three things about that I've got
the reins in the wrong hand
that is my brother pakes
care for open horse he wasn't working
too good for Pake so Pake said I could
run barrels on him and I am rocking the
plaid pants yes you are yes you are man
Fashion Icon before
um we're really even hit okay next oh
that day Kelly I won a car for six
months what I would have won a Ford
Torino car for six months and all you
had to do is fill out your little uh
questionnaire thing and then that is the
Kiowa Cowboy High School band right
there oh my god oh you see the guy on
the right Roger Wheels he he is the band
leader for Alan Jackson oh and then
Susie's in the middle and Pake on the
left and Gary Rayburn and Kelly Ryan
your whole family sings That's What I
find I know that and I know a lot of
people do know that but it's insane like
I'm talking like everyone sings like
well like it's crazy well Daddy I
somebody asked daddy one time said Clark
do you do you play he said I used to
play on the linoleum
[Laughter]
he loved you I love it I like okay next
okay oh my gosh oh that's why NoDa and
Trisha Trisha yeah Bruce Hinton yeah
[Music]
look at your hair you are so cute look
at all y'all are so cute when was that I
don't know when did you all have are
those records uh-huh go through all your
records yeah oh my God this is what I'm
talking about see this is 90s country
right here like all these women
representing right now and like they
don't play women now hardly on Country
what's wrong with y'all they're missing
out I know next oh look he's there that
was for the Duets album it was you came
and sang with me it was so magical it's
so funny because remember we actually
recorded a different song first and then
we ended up in Crossroads and then we
ended up doing because of you and it was
such a magical moment Kelly we look so
young I know I still look good I know
where you're talking shut up
okay this is a little thing we'd like to
call of the wind down
[Applause]
why what kind of pranks he's always
pranking you got him well we all got him
good time because Karen was when Karen
was pregnant with their son and real
pregnant you're in the studio and Jimmy
left to give this baby I was like I get
it I gave it off so we I said come on
girls we can pretend and uh pretend like
your water broke oh my God Jimmy was in
the bathroom that is terrible right
and we're in the studio together and we
like took a water bottle and the floor
and when he came around from the
bathroom we were like Jimmy she was
standing there and there's water all
over the place what the freak oh my God
yeah and then they all got to watch you
I squealed amazing he's hard to get so I
love it yeah Kimberly who's the messiest
on the tour bus well Phillip because he
spills a lot we call him because he's
drinking
Karen who's the biggest crier Phillip
[Applause]
literally like surely I feel like you're
getting picked up here man
yeah I love that it's not the winner
I want to talk about humble Quest why
did you aim at that
um I named it humble Quest because I
like I had my son at the beginning of
covid like as everything shut down and
it's my first boy like my first kid
really and so it was so much uncertainty
of like what I'm bringing a baby into
the most chaotic time of human history
right now or at least of our lifetimes
and then also all my touring got
canceled and you know for the last two
years so it was just I don't know like
humbling for the worlds to go through
these last few and for me as someone
that's like
I mean I hate to say this in a very
self-indulgent industry
um everything being shut down gave me a
lot of perspective and made I didn't
feel like it took it for granted before
because that seems kind of hyperbolic
but I definitely appreciate it even more
now being able to like I think a lot of
music yeah yeah and you get to tour like
people are just now touring again right
yeah and so it just felt kind of apropos
to name it humble Quest because it's
like it's an ongoing Journey it's not
going to end like the second I go back
on stage it's going to be
um Evergreen so yeah yeah that's kind of
once you're like I know they're all our
babies like on our Amazon what's like
your one that you're in love with right
now
um which song oh my God okay the song
Hummingbird I wrote the day I found out
I was pregnant and then I had my son at
the beginning of 2020 and then it was
just about like like the line is oh he's
adorable oh God yeah that's him wow in
the back of him but the line in the
chorus is like like hummingbird now your
heart beats in me and it's by the time I
was recording the song with my producer
Greg my son was starting to talk and so
at the top of that song you hear a
little like voice memo recording of him
just saying mama and so I I mean oh I
love that it's hard to pick one but like
that one I think I'm I don't know if I'm
going to be able to get through live but
yeah I hate when I do that when you
write something that you need to get out
and you want to get out and share but
like and then you're like oh I get to do
this for the rest of my life yeah yeah
and it's like intense so wait so this is
my favorite story that I've heard about
you because I heard that you it was you
were doing music and everything but it
just wasn't hitting like you wanted it
wasn't hitting you got a big huge family
and I heard that you this could be wrong
but you were at Costco and you were
shopping whatever for all your family
with a lot of kids and so and is it
someone that came up to you and asked
for an autograph oh yeah and then you
ended up working for Costco yeah this
guy he came up to me and he wanted my
autograph on his napkin and he mentioned
you know that he he worked at Costco in
the tire center and I needed an
overnight job and um you know I was just
like I was embarrassed because he wanted
he wanted to be a musician also and I
was like it's not that fun man you know
and then I was like by the way I was
like if I give you your this autograph
can you put in a good word for me at
Costco and we honestly at first he was a
little like dang you know and then but
we became buddies yeah and um can I tell
you like that and that is real like
everybody who thinks American Idol that
was my first thing I ever did and it
wasn't you literally I had like four
jobs to maintain living here and trying
to make it and people don't get that
because their pride and ego get in the
way and it's like you know what you just
need to provide like that's a grown ass
man and it's so unbelievable and I feel
like that's why good things happen to
people whoa that put that out in the
University you know my fan family they
were always supportive my kids didn't
ever know you know that they don't care
whether you're poor you know they're
happy and then my wife Laney
um you know she never never at one time
was like Hey this dream's a bad idea you
know she just she just was glad that I
loved what I did yeah you know and
supported that was that was fine you
know it was enough for her and so you
know she she wrote me a note every
single morning I went to work at Costco
I would leave the house at three and
there was always a letter and like a
lunch I mean she you know and I it was
it was amazing I mean she she was so
supportive that year of my life and so
yeah I'm glad in that now you know I can
buy our dogs named Puckett
but it's just the greatest story because
people think you hit like are you you're
in the music industry and it just all of
a sudden every door opens and it doesn't
like right off the bat you you have to
work and you have to do things like
aren't really what you want to be doing
but you do them because you've got to
pay electricity like for that and all
the things but let's talk about some
favorites um so what inspired the dance
and I'm sitting at the bluebird I was
probably about seven or eight of us a
guy named Tony Arata was sitting there
playing and uh Tony starts in on this
song and when he gets done with it I'm
just I'm just amazed and nobody else in
the room seems to be
getting the same reaction that I'm
getting and so I take it to Alan
Reynolds Alan Reynolds says he loves it
and we keep waiting and keep waiting and
finally I don't really goes how come we
haven't cut the dance yet because the
album was almost over I said I'm not
sure that it's country enough what you
know because I mean just being from
Oklahoma and it had piano in it which
you know I moved to Nashville to know
what a piano was because you know it's
always just Steals and fiddles yes but
your voice is country music thank you
you tie it in yeah it's funny because
that's what he said and he told me he
said pal I'm going to tell you right now
you always use the word pal he says if
you don't cut the dance if you don't
record that song It'll be the biggest
hit you never have oh wow yeah it's cool
oh my challenge accepted oh it's just
yeah it's just uh what's the um
oh thank you
looking back
oh quit don't do that
dang it dude like I can't believe
like life
a bag and Mary McConnell all my friends
from childhood hate me right now
I'm so sorry April she's the one that
introduced you to me and I like I feel
like I'm stealing her moment
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]